l'amertume de la défaite par exemple à
les primaires auraient pu vous
découragez jamais vous n'avez jamais eu
cette pensée oui ça aurait pu me
décourager c'est vrai parce que ce sont
comme des épreuves des épreuves
difficiles et en temps quand j'étais les
apps et du film du bourget d'agir comme
un peu de vérité un peu de respect des
choses en ont été rétablies et
maintenant on peut importe je dis non
c'est bon c'est les abysses et
l'essentiel c'est pas se déplacer du
candidat je peux vous dire que
j'ai pas besoin d'être boosté je suis
utile dans cette campagne j'apporte ce
que je tout ce que je peux apporter et
d'ailleurs si 2012 arrive si nous gagne
en 2012 ce que je pense c'est peut-être
parce qu'il y ait aussi 2007 et qui est
ces étapes là peut-être aussi parce
qu'il ya eu 2002 donc c'est la
construction et la muleta à répéter les
mêmes erreurs qu'en 2007 pareil à la
volonté de ne pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs et il ya surtout des chemins
nouveaux et des voies ouvertes qui ont
été posées comme ça vient d'être dit
dans votre reportage et que d'ailleurs
françois hollande assume totalement et
reconnaît totalement dans ses
interventions ont été corrigés à la
désunion des socialistes
effectivement qu'elle semble loin
derrière le candidat et vous vous étiez
un peu de soles exactement bon tome on
le sait n'est pas un tabou donc cette
leçon a été tirée et prend soin des rae
rae dit lui même dans une de ses
interventions publiques nous avons tiré
la leçon de la division il l'a dit même
à rennes